welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and marvel's loki has a new special
look trailer with new clues and easter
eggs and reasons to love this god of
mischief for the madman he is
because it can't be easy to keep that
smile on your face while watching so
many worlds burn or while time hopping
back to a day like this
so let's watch this special look and
break it down as i try to explain the
new shots of dimensions between
dimensions so that we're all a little
less lost when this series premieres
let's go and now a special look at
marvel studios original series
loki maybe loki wants to mix it up
is that possible you can change
hi all right the special look opens on
this wide shot of the time variance
authority archives according to those
wall signs in the lower left and right
corners like all corners of the tva
headquarters it's adorned by the massive
looming statues of its three founders
the time keepers
in the comics these figures are created
at the end of all time by a guy called
he who remains the final surviving tva
agent
in order to help the next universal
cycle learn from the mistakes of the
past
and to store chronal energy for tva
agents retirement
i know it's bonkers and i love it but i
suspect that timekeeper's godlike
reputation will ultimately be subverted
on the show
the way loki's towering shrine do
himself in ragnarok was toppled when
thor
outed his trickery one possibility for
this subversion is that one of those
timekeepers could have broken away from
the other two
to become the time-traveling villain
kang the conqueror based on
a similar appearance kang's longtime
association with the tba in the comics
his romantic history with google
authorized character ravana rinslayer
and the way rent slayer is framed in
that timekeeper's
lips and of course kang's confirmed
arrival to be played by jonathan majors
in ant-man in the wasp quantomania
release date february 2023 the movie's
predecessor left that easter egg of a
quantum realm city
widely believed to be kang's residence
of chronopolis
quite a run-on way of me saying i'm in
the kang gang here loki faces rinse lair
in the tva time court he was detained by
the chrono monitor hunter b15
played by actress woonmimosaku known for
her roles in the snyder ultimate cut of
batman v superman as well as lovecraft
country and black mirror
a show where she psychologically
tortured john walker actor wyatt russell
so yeah i
am pumped to see her now with this
marvel bad boy there's this new shot of
four chrono monitors in this burning
field we've seen another footage where a
hooded figure attacks them
this is sofia di martino's character
still unconfirmed but believed to be
either enchantress but more likely
lady loki an alternate female form of
loki in the comics maybe in this show
the most dangerous loki variant created
by
our variant loki's initial breach from
the time stream
with lady loki going on to cause further
chaos and now the loose end that our
loki is tasked with hunting down now
among the chrono monitor's gear here is
the shovel
with a glowing clock on it maybe a kind
of device to unearth what once
was or what will be one day buried in a
certain location which lady loki is now
trying to steal from the tva
then owen wilson's character mobius
immobius defends the loki variant to
rinse layers saying loki wants to mix it
up is that possible he can change
wow well ironically loki can change
using his sorcery to shapeshift part of
what makes him so
untrustworthy loki checks in with a tva
clerk by dinging this vintage brass
hotel bell just another example of the
great retro production design of the
series
despite the tva's seemingly infinite
access and insight to the multiverse
their offices still use
old-school desk bells and elevator doors
dot matrix printers bulbous monitors all
these tangled wires
all as a way to convey the red tape and
archaic
limitations of their bureaucracy like
they could be gods if not for their
intricate burdensome rules
and apparently going rogue within the
tva loki gives this
wave hi reminding me a bit of that
similar moment with heath ledger's joker
in the dark knight
hi that's gonna be my first line when
i'm indoors in a public place and we're
allowed to take our masks off again
hi anyway moving on this variant is
insubordinate
stubborn
he's doing great you need the god of
mischief
but he's really arrogant nice a glorious
wide shot of the full tva headquarters
this is situated in the null
time zone a marvel dimension that's kind
of removed from time and space let's
break down all the cool stuff we can see
notice the white void backdrop matching
the vacant backdrop behind the 3d grid
of chrono monitor desks in the comics
now we did see some of this in the last
trailer from a lower angle where mobius
and mobius and loki were standing but
here you can see a pulled back angle
with shuttles
zipping among the platforms and then
this central tower
propped up atlas style by the time
keepers maybe this is their primary
mission control
look closely ribboned around that
platform is a red orange beam that kinda
angled crookedly
perhaps representing the normal flow of
the time stream
shown on the screens in the other
trailer as loki was splitting it but
above that
ribbon is another projected ticker
rotating clockwise
maybe showing updates to the way this
time stream has been altered and then as
ren slayer calls our loki variant
insubordinate stubborn and unpredictable
we see loki using a sorcery to
shape-shift during that stormy rocks
cart mission from soaking wet to dry
and then the moment when mobius takes
him to pompeii the moment of its
destruction
and we know this is pompeii because the
first trailer featured roman numerals
reading number 79
the year pompeii was destroyed by the
eruption of mount vesuvius and in case
it was hard to make out loki shouts
right on cue delighted to use the chaos
of this eruption i guess to try to lose
mobius but before we continue a big
thanks to our sponsor helix for
sponsoring this video
see folks goldilocks was right sleeping
in a bed designed for someone else goes
bad at least two-thirds of the time
quit sleeping on the wrong kind of
mattress and get yourself a personalized
helix mattress
helix mattresses are made in america and
shipped to your door with free delivery
free returns and a 100 night sleep trial
to choose a mattress helix made a quiz
that takes just two minutes and matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you if you like
a mattress that's really soft or really
firm if you sleep on your side or on
your stomach or if you sleep really hot
with helix there's a specific mattress
for your unique taste i took the quiz
and got matched with the dusk
luxe helix mattress because i wanted a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
it sleeps cool
and i sleep great on my helix mattress
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
wired magazine and apartment therapy
go to helix sleep.com rockstars take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress for
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
rockstars that's helix sleep.com
rockstars for up to 200
off and two free pillows now while this
volcano is mount vesuvius
since obviously no one has video footage
of that eruption the vfx team here
used the visual of the eruption of mount
saint helens in washington state
in 1980 and what's interesting about
that is
this is the same region of the pacific
northwest where
nine years earlier in 1971 db cooper's
hijacked plane flew
over and route from portland to seattle
when he jumped out of that plane and was
mysteriously never
found except for a couple bills of the
money he got floating around in the
columbia river
in that event this series is justified
as the doing of
loki add that to the sighting of the
plebious arcade game and urban legend
linked to government mind control
conspiracy theories that
originated in the portland area in 1981
so while obviously we are looking at the
eruption of mount vesuvius and pompei in
79 a.d
visually this series is pulling freaky
historical references
from a 10-year period in a very specific
region of the united states
why don't you dare say mephisto i just
think it's an interesting coincidence
that we should definitely keep our eye
on and roll that final clip
i am loki and i am burdened with
glorious purpose
unbelievable wherever you go it's just
death destruction the literal
ends of worlds i know
okay once again we see this awesome shot
of a moon crashing into some planet's
surface
we could be looking at the universe
itself coming to an end with gravity
just
given out causing planets to collapse
upon each other
because notice how mobius tells loki
everywhere you go literal death
destruction the ends of worlds
and while loki's response of i know is
actually from a different scene the
cafeteria not the
this was your life scene where loki's
still in his detainee jumpsuit
mobius is right loki has presided over
the ends of
civilizations from asgard burning under
searcher's strike
to new apocalyptic ends in this show
like pompeii like the ruins of manhattan
after an alternate battle of new york
where he wins
and then now this crashing moon it is
precisely this experience as the god of
mischief that mobius needs to repair a
multiverse now
unraveling by its seams and to me the
most interesting shot here is this
jagged rock ring is suspended in this
kind of nebulous space
upon the axis of some vibrant blue
horizon line
kind of like something you'd see in 2001
a space odyssey this could be the last
surviving chunk of real estate at the
end of all time
after various planetary collisions where
he who remains creates the timekeepers
and or the final resting place of kang
prime
as he feeds off chronal energy from the
time stream
as all past variants of the kang dynasty
alter their histories to benefit him now
here
loki declares i am loki and i am
burdened with glorious purpose
and that word again glorious which he
utters when back at the top of stark
tower in the other footage
reliving the battle of new york from the
first avengers film
glorious these are the words of loki
from that era when he was still on a
mission with that
scepter which was powered by the mind
stone making loki further corrupted by
its cosmic divine intelligence by the
way we may be looking at a series with
multiple loki variants
in one scene at a time since footage
tells us that we will see president loki
in the same kind of setting as a
different loki in tva attire
and we end on loki's db cooper jump and
the bifrost catch
now if this series does try to justify
that real world db cooper mystery as
just the doing of loki
as i explained in a recent big question
episode that would classify this series
and perhaps
all of time travel in the mcu as what i
call type 4
this always happened time travel which
means that seemingly random unexplained
phenomena early in history
are later revealed to be the result of
time traveling that the characters are
destined to carry out
confused don't you worry you're in good
hands with this time
travel nerd whoever thinks everything as
your guide to loki and the multiverse so
be sure to follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos
subscribe to new rockstars as we gear up
for our loki analysis
and support this channel by checking out
our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you